all right what came first the chicken or
the egg it's a riddle that's still hard
to crack Brian no matter what the answer
is we do know egg prices and Supply
nowhere near what they were last year
Victoria Saha shows us what some Valley
residents are resorting to so they don't
have to go too far to get the popular
breakfast item
if you're someone who loves eating eggs
unable to find them in the store
chickens so they never have to worry
about having a supply of eggs
our birds were for meat the turkeys and
Amanda manuela's backyard now have a new
purpose this is the first year we're
gonna eat them because of egg costs
because High egg prices are no yolk my
jaw dropped they were a dollar fifty a
year ago her turkeys lay eggs one month
out of a year I get so excited when they
start laying it's it's you did it it's a
thicker shell than a chicken egg gotta
work for it the turkey eggs weren't
enough for her family so she bought
chickens it is like having an animal but
with a benefit they're feeding my house
it'll be a few more weeks until her
chickens can lay eggs but there's a
sunny side to look forward to it wasn't
just the egg prices it's also
reliability the manuelos aren't the only
ones getting into the backyard chicken
Biz there's a Facebook group with more
than 4 000 members here at Jones Feed
and Tack they say they get hundreds of
these little chicks delivered every week
but they're sold out within a day it's
like toilet paper when the covet hit
the demand so high their customers can
only buy five chicks at a time 15 to 20
there will be like one customer trying
to buy them all the next time Ben
Wallace goes to the grocery store she
won't be chickened out by the cost free
range ones are still in the tens I have
that
and we're told each chick can cost about
five dollars and can live up to five
years before you start to build a
chicken coop you have to remember that
some parts of the valley do not allow it
so make sure to check the guidelines for
your area